I was a good workout yeah okay so our
reservations at 7:00 so we should leave
at like 6:30 all right you better get
going right all I have to do is hop in
the shower which takes you 45 minutes
honestly I don't know what you're doing
in there
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going as fast as I can right and
then you have to do your hair if I want
to look my best it takes time
[Music]
all I'm saying is if you didn't wait
time you could be as fast as I am okay
you're on good great great perfect easy
here we go
I'm almost there winner winner did the
shower chicken dinner
speedy Gonzalez okay babe seriously go
get ready
let's go I'm already ready this is fast
as you ready let's go
[Music]